[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to another
episode of chappelle's world uh yeah i
ain't done yet i got more to say that's
why i'm here by myself again
i got a lot to talk about you know and i
like talking i'm loving this narcissism
game
i'm having a great time with it casey
you know that's my world what'd you say
startled me why because i'm a narcissist
that's what narcissists do they startle
people
yeah
boo
yeah exactly
i'm the crimson ghost
whatever that looks like uh it looks
like a no it looks like a fiend skull
you know what fiend skull is
basically there
one away
you'll see it that
i call it a fiend skull the misfits
thing yeah i have a tattooed on me right
on watch
sick yeah
that's like my uh
my mom tattoo
that's what the fiend skull is for me
you know how people get the heart and
the mom i have that do you really
no you don't i do
oh
casey
well shout out to casey first of all
casey out here showing off that body
calm down dude i'm not gonna cut that on
i won't cut to that when i do that no
hey you're going to
hey you need to spice things up a little
bit ain't nothing wrong with that
um dude i got back uh i spent time
spent time well i was doing shows in uh
springfield missouri
and i have been raving
about this place
i love
i'm saying right here right now
i love springfield missouri springfield
missouri is probably one of the best
cities
not only just to perform in yeah look at
dude i got to sit on a bear live in your
bed who can do that who can say that in
any city that you get to sit on a bear
where are you going to find a bear
statue like that
where
show me another city that has a bear
statue and i'm not talking no don't show
me your bear standing up like
no no no a bear like that
show me that kind of bear where do you
have that at i googled it it doesn't
exist it doesn't exist
exactly and i had casey right here to
google it and guess what does not exist
no but real talk dude i listen
i'm gonna be honest i had low
expectations
for this city you know i never heard of
it but also like at the same time you
know when i go somewhere i like to you
know
try not to have like
these expectations like i'm going to
just you know just like drop them and
i'm not saying that in a mean way
i was dropping their expectations i just
you know was a cycle in springfield
missouri
never
heard of it you know most people talk
about st louis
when they talk about missouri
unless there's another city in missouri
that other people talk about
besides st louis kansas city
yes okay yes yes kansas city okay so you
got that but
bruh
i think spring feel better than all
those wow now listen i haven't been to
st louis in a minute
okay i haven't been to st louis since i
was
uh cheering at university of louisville
okay
that was the last time i went to uh
st louis but springfield was popping it
was just such a vibe out there like it's
weird it's like a
it's a it's a smaller town
but like but big vibes
big comfortable
accepting vibes does that make any sense
shut up meatball you didn't go to school
but anyways
it was just like the perfect town their
claim to fame route 66. i guess that's
where it originated you know and
remember that commercial get your kicks
at route 66. remember those shoes
what what were they like skater style
we pull those up
route 66 shoes
are trash
listen okay look at that listen
let me tell you that doesn't match the
vibe of springfield missouri that's a
disrespect if springfield was a shoe no
no no it's helped you do that
don't you dare say that about
springfield missouri
how dare you that can't be what you're
talking about no listen i thought route
66 route 66 shoes were a lot cooler than
that i didn't know they would look like
that
okay that is not do
springfield missouri justice okay and i
didn't realize because uh you know i
dropped out that route 66 goes like
you could pretty much take it i think
from there to like l.a
yeah or am i tripping no i think you
could i think it goes all the way to
hawaii
that's a road joke
how dare you disrespect my lack of
college intelligence it's a long road
great yeah it's a long time but i didn't
know that it went all the way
down there you know or to la i don't
know
i just know it's the original yeah how
long's it go
what's it say evidently it only goes to
vegas
so it goes all the way to santa monica
dude they don't make roads like that
anymore
you know i mean how many roads you got
to take to get to
texas bro you know how many roads you
got to take to get to orange county who
cares though you know it's a road
why y'all hate it listen
listen i'm trying to show my love for
springfield well give us more than they
have a road they have a bear okay they
have shitty shoes no no
oh gosh okay you know what man listen
this is
okay this is then this happiness about
springfield missouri is only for me and
the people of spring the great people of
springfield missouri they got uh they
got a bass pro shop that's like three
levels
okay and it's got an aquarium in it i
guess it's the biggest
best pro shop
in the country this is not a ringing
endorsement listen you better
hey let me get to the parts i'm just
walking i'm warming you up we're five
minutes in
i'm warming you up at
this
listen okay now granted i did not go to
that bass pro shop because why would i
why would i go to a bass pro shop
and and that was the thing i remember
when when i did a poll not a poll uh i
did a
ig story saying hey tell me the things
to do in springfield missouri
and people were like man you gotta go to
that bass pro shop
why the hell would i go to a bass pro
shop
what am i gonna find in a bass pro shop
for me
maybe some sick camo stuff
i see you wearing those super tight uh
thick boy pants hey listen that's okay
listen
that has nothing to do with bass pro
shop okay
casey that's fair no it's it's just you
know i just have no desire to ever go to
a bass pro shop now let me tell you what
else
springfield missouri has a great
downtown
it's dude the downtown great restaurants
great coffee shops we went to this uh
breakfast spot every morning called
gayley's
which was poppin
uh
and then we went to
this late uh later like at late night
bar restaurant
spot called uh j-o-b everyone kept
calling it j-o-b i was like why can't we
just say job you know why can't we just
say job and call it that it was like you
gotta go j-o-b's hey
jobs
just say jobs and we'll leave it at that
so yeah we went to that and oh i tell
you what else they're known for
cashew chicken
that's that's another claim to fame in
springfield missouri see everybody
talking all that all that crap like
ain't got nothing there they ain't got
nothing there no they got a lot they're
claimed like the claim to fames in
springfield missouri are great claim to
fames
listen i don't give a damn about bass
pro shop but hey a lot there's a lot of
people out there that do
enough people to make it three levels
and at an aquarium a minute
hey
are you going to stop those people from
going there because it's
good luck
what'd you say good luck good luck
stopping them yeah good luck stopping
them you know let these people
rise to the top in springfield missouri
bro they got the dopest coffee shops
okay now listen here's the thing about
springfield missouri there's a lot of
rule
a lot of uh
get it off that
why you gotta zoom in on that photo that
looks so chunky your face isn't like i
look like a chunky kid
but anyways uh what was i talking about
they're shitty uh coffee no no they're
great coffee shops dude oh yeah yeah no
the thing about spring for missouri so
it's a lot of farmland a lot of land a
lot of
you know you get you get your people
that are country folk all right and
whenever i go into towns like that
all right i'll tell you this one thing
they all have their little hipster areas
all those all those little small towns
like that
you'll find you a hipster area and i
found mine
i found mine at this coffee shop i think
it was called kingdom
i guess it used to be part of a church
and then they were like oh we don't
really do all that and so they stayed
you know where they're where they're at
or whatever but we went there
fascinating coffee and guess what listen
this is this is how i feel good about
the coffee shops when i know it's gonna
be good when you see that rainbow flag
sticking out that coffee shop oh
you know about to be lit latte's on
point you know the latte is on point you
know the menu is small
they don't have a crazy menu you know
they got a couple breakfast things on it
right
a little boutique
of a of a shop don't be surprised if you
see a little scone on there a little
scone on there i hate scones but yeah
screw scones a little bit trash but
excellent
did you were you able to get any sense
of the music scene out there while you
were there uh no because it was honestly
it's kind of it's a pretty diverse
out there it's not just like i don't
know there's a lot of layers to that
town more than like people would
actually give it credit for
you know like
you know there was white dudes out there
bumping me ghosts what
in springfield missouri
yeah migos makes their way out there
you know i heard drake a couple times
but drake's kind of universal but like i
didn't think migos would make it to
springfield
you know i know they've been killing the
south the west coast
you know a little bit of the north area
but i didn't i didn't know
i don't know they were going to make it
out that way like that
shout out to migos
[ __ ] amazing you know what i mean
but um
no pretty diverse town
great food
people are really nice i had great times
at the shows
um
there was i mean only one night that i
kind of wanted to kick someone in the
chest
uh
this dude
so this dude sit in front row
at the show
and uh you know he's got a trump hat on
a blazer
jeans and jordans right kind of like a
bro jockey
kind of vibe i guess not even jockey
more so like fraternity i don't even
know if it's fraternity i don't know
what i'm trying to say you know you get
the style of who this guy is
but
he was really drunk
and he just kept
doing random things like one who tried
to talk to me i go you're not the only
one in the room i can't just talk to you
whatever blah blah
made uh
you know some jokes of it then he goes
on
but then he stopped talking to me right
now he's trying to film me i go don't do
that either you know then he stops
filming me so like he was being
respectful when i would say stop doing
something it's just he would find
another thing to do and he was so drunk
that i don't that's why i didn't go too
hard on him because i don't think he
realized then he uh
what did he do he um
oh then after he stopped filming then he
tried to talk to the to these two girls
at the next table trying to hit on them
and then i was like hey hey you know
just broke it down to him that's why he
should stop then he gets moved to the
back right because i was like i don't
want him kicked out he's like
like every time i had to address him it
wasn't in like in such a crazy way
then he gets moved to the back
right
then he then he's chilling back he's
being quiet the whole time
then out of nowhere some guy in the
audience
goes hey let me see your hat
to to to the dude right let me see your
head goes right up front go comes right
up front and sits there and acts like
hey i'm the new guy
i was like bro i should kick you in the
[ __ ] chest and people thought it was
a plan people thought i planted him
to do that
i was like what
i was like
what were you like getting laughs
is that why people thought it was like a
they were in on it like when you when
went in on them were you like was it
getting laughs yeah and i think that's
probably yeah you're right that's
probably why people thought it was a
plant and i was like why would i why
would i do that why would i do that to
the beautiful city of springfield
missouri what this doesn't do that
doesn't do
justice yeah home of route 66 yeah some
terrible shoes and a
bucket lot casey good good lattes
oh a nice smoker in springfield oh
you'll find a great one but anyways so
anyways this dude comes up and he then
he comes up to me after the show they
always do this [ __ ] where oh man i
thought i thought
you know it would be
it would be funny
i'm like no eat a dick like you're there
looking to collaborate yeah i was like
so you i was like you think i just come
up on stage i have nothing to talk about
and hopes
that somebody like you i know just all
right somebody saved me right now in
hopes
to make so i can make laughter
that's what you think i do you think i
go to every city and just go hey someone
interrupt me
please i beg of thee
no eat a dick
eat a dick so anyways
he and and i was more appreciative of
the other the original dude because he
came up to me after and said hey man
this is my first time at a comedy show i
don't really know comedy etiquette you
know and it was weird the way he was
talking because i was like bro you were
so drunk
sitting front row or whatever they might
have cut him off or whatever he probably
was able to tone him down a little bit
he goes i didn't mean to disrespect you
like that and i hope you can forgive me
so it's actually pretty nice you know
what i mean so i wasn't gonna kick his
chest in but the dude that took his hat
and sat up front like he was doing
something funny dude
what made me mad
what made me mad is when he sat up front
he goes he goes
he goes
and i was like bro i will [ __ ]
kill you
i will [ __ ] kill you you just gotta
like it was a damn tv show like you know
when someone walks in like a like a
celebrity guest on a tv show and the
girl's like
he thought that was his intro he thought
he was going to get an applause break
yeah he thought he was going to get an
applause break he thought people were
like but no it was so funny because i
you know yeah i ripped on him a little
bit but the crowd you know some people
in the crowd were like pissed that he
did that because some people obviously
got to catch some other people thought
it was a plant you know what i mean but
some people got the catch and was like
yo
what are you doing they're like yo don't
do that move
security came and got with stuff but
shout out to springfield missouri man if
you're ever if you're ever out there
you know
i just gave you a whole recommendations
of place places to go
you know and don't say
you know and when you go there and you
have a great time give me the credit
give the credit to me
because i who else who else is talking
about springfield missouri
i'll wait
exactly
exactly and i hope like next time i go
there i'll sell that whole out
dude you know what was crazy is uh tom
segura was performing
at a theater
um like literally four minute walk on on
the same street but like a four minute
walk from each other from where i was uh
performing he was performing there he
was doing an early and late show i think
he performed on 311 shouts out to 311
hey
he performed on 311 day
and uh
what was cool is that people that went
to
his early show came to my late show and
then vice versa people that came to my
early show
went to his like late show so it was
actually cool
um
you know it's like oh people that [ __ ]
with thompson also [ __ ] with me so it
was just a cool feeling because i really
like tom segura he's he's one of my uh
top favorites you know so stop playing
and answering my dm's dawg anyways uh
maybe he went to the bass pro shops
is that your question is that a real
question nah is that a real question no
come on casey you better or not
you better not
i mean three floors
i'm just saying i don't know why you
didn't hold it up see what it type in
springfield okay what is it called uh
bass pro shop
oh yeah it's the one with the aquarium
or whatever
not or whatever it's the one with the
aquarium
that's the one
uh-huh
i would literally
all right i
i know i can listen i'll get off
springfield for my listeners that have
no desire to ever go there okay cool
oh i would never go there why does he
keep talking about this please
anyways uh i would film a special there
that's how electrifying those those audi
those
that crowd those crowds were you should
film a special at the aquarium
[Laughter]
i would never do that i would film it
it's [ __ ]
outside of the aquarium but
that's that's how good it was listen
when you think of dope cities when you
think of like
uh new york you think of atlantic city
you think of miami
you think of seattle chicago
you better throw a [ __ ] springfield
missouri in there
you better throw some respect on my name
yep throw some respect on springfield
missouri's name man uh let's uh let's
take a break from this episode right now
to talk about one of the uh best kratoms
in the game happy hippo i use kratom to
fire my brain before any shows podcasts
or even uh my punk rock shows uh which
are going to be starting soon and it's a
great focus product probably one of the
best that i've used it's all natural
okay so you don't have to worry about
anything crazy going into your body
that's gonna mess you up make you feel
weird it's natural it'll take care of
you don't stress
once you visit happyhippo herbals.com
and use promo code thick boy for 20 off
for life okay use that code as many
times as you want once again that's
happy hippo herbals.com and using promo
code promo code thick boy for that 20
off
since the kanye dock is over
um
it made me think about i was
have you ever seen the jay-z
dock
the when did it come out is that oh my
gosh it's old one i i want to say
jay-z yeah
the
no
wait scroll up
the fade to black
oh so it came out in 2004
all right rotten tomatoes chill out
giving it a 58 percent
gosh you eat a dick
is round tomatoes usually accurate
yeah
disrespectful
disrespectful
they they they didn't watch it anyways
if they watched it now they'd be like
one thousand percent
you know uh but yeah what i don't know
if you ever seen this document so this
is another really good documentary this
is when he came out with his black album
the one that's got like 99 problems in
the [ __ ]
it's got encore
uh
what mom can i say you got got all the
stuff all the hits uh exchange clothes
anyways i watched that doc
and
i forgot i forgot to mention this last
time but man you know you see these
things in
certain certain artists that are like
super [ __ ] successful and you see
this this uh
hunger and he had it too and so this is
basically following him
when he was selling out madison square
he sold out a few nights at madison
square garden
right
i wonder if he was the first rapper to
do that i doubt it
i actually i doubt it because it i would
assume run dmc did before he did
uh but yeah he he sold out a few nights
at madison square garden and this was
like you know
maybe the start of the start of his tour
for his black album
and uh
dude
think about selling out madison square
garden this is what's cool about him
and he said man i just want to do good
think about you already sold it out
people already showed up you go i just
want to do good
that level of like like
that's what keeps a person like going
and like staying successful
you know
that's how i felt when i was in
springfield i just wanted to
[Laughter]
before i walked out there casey first of
all i was walking in i was walking into
the cold weather to the club from the
hotel
freezing my ass off
every night
and i was just like man i just want to
do good
you know that's hey that's where i'm at
casey
you couldn't bring it up that's the
caption for this i just want to do good
i just want to do good
no that's the name of this episode
yeah we're gonna do the episode i just
want to do good i just want to do good i
just want to do good but uh
so yeah follows him you know leading up
to his madison square garden and it
follows him making the black album and
you know i've always [ __ ] with jay-z
on a dope level i've seen him live and
one of the one thing i loved about him
is that literally
he was the only person on stage
he didn't have a billion people
coming out on stage with them which
drives me crazy
and i probably mentioned this before it
drives me crazy because i'm like if
you're up there
and you're just jumping around
no you can eat a dick
roll off the stage roll off the stage
because because listen
either do some choreography
okay make up a dance you and the other
people that aren't really doing anything
why don't y'all go back there and make
up a dance
to help to help the lead
singer the artists
you know
put out their work why don't you do that
why didn't they why did why don't these
these people that are just jumping and
bouncing around on stage 50 [ __ ]
people oh you could do a dope ass dance
and then the crowd can join in what
do that when in doubt make a dance when
in doubt make a [ __ ] dance
and that's one thing i appreciate about
jay-z but i mean obviously he had his
feature people that were featured on
songs come out but you know as soon as
that song was over or does [ __ ]
believe
you know what i mean that's what they
would do and that's what i love it's
like yeah come out do your song
and then get the [ __ ] off the stage
right there the song's over but no these
[ __ ] who aren't any even i
don't even know if they're rappers
probably not rappers they're just
entourage all right
i'm gonna need the entourage of all
these artists to [ __ ]
you know
do some choreography make up a dance
something
do something you think you'll ever have
an entourage
no
i couldn't even if you hit that level
you wouldn't have one like kevin hills
like the solo cup guys no that's the
i think it's plastic cup boys
i think yeah who would be in your
entourage let's say hypothetically
not meatball not meatball
i'd be there though not meatball man me
yeah you'd be happy yeah i i i would
feel i don't know the whole entourage
thing makes me feel weird
because i'm kind of just a like a just
an individual myself you know what i
mean like
obviously if i'm around friends i'm
around friends it's not like i'd be like
oh hey there's too many too many friends
around me right now i gotta hey i gotta
be an individual i gotta move away no no
i'm talking about in that sense yeah
like i don't like care to like bring
people on the road with me or anything i
don't really care to like
because if because if you're not doing
anything in the world then you're just
kind of hanging
and i don't need someone to hang with
i hang out with my journal
oh you laugh
no i was i was thinking about you
laughing no i was thinking are you
laughing i was thinking about you on the
bear i kill you shut the [ __ ] up
that's like
it's like a christian thing to say i
hang out with my bible
thank you very much
you know i don't know if that's a
christian thing or someone just
religious
uh but uh wasn't talking about
how you respect the hell out of jay-z
for being a solo dude oh dude yeah so
anyways but uh
you know
i don't know and i it's just such a
to me like looking at a person
yeah i guess it's just like stand up too
like because we're up there by ourselves
so i guess that's why i respect that so
much that makes sense you know from
jay-z and i get because it's like yeah
what if i brought up people while i'm
telling jokes
there's one there's one uh
one time i think it was uh it was cat
williams he was in
phoenix doing celebrity theater
and which is like celebrity theater in
phoenix is a circular stage
and uh he
had women sitting on the side
the whole time and the stage
spins slowly but he had women just
sitting there casually like
like what they're you know how like
their legs out like this
you know so and they had to sit there
for his whole set
i love cat williams
but you don't co-sign that no i would
never go bruh
hey those ladies better be getting paid
bank
if they're sitting there
the whole time
that's a different level of stand up
some people love that theatric [ __ ] i'm
just not you know for stand up and jc
didn't really have any theatrics or
anything it was just him in a circular
stage and he was just
bars
bars oh
but no anyways it makes sense why
i love seeing that you know that in the
inside of what a person does it and you
understand why it's like oh that makes
sense why they have the level of success
that they have you know and the way
you know they come up with the things
that they want to come up with and their
concepts behind it because yeah because
i'm looking at it like as a person
that's just a fan of music they're like
damn like how do how did he come up with
you know
99 problems how did he come up with like
how did he why how did he make it to
that and it's just dope you know
watching him do it and like he doesn't
write anything down
he just goes in there yeah i've heard
that like what
but he's been doing that since junk
lil wayne's that same way
he just goes in there you know
he he i think the lil wayne's story is
he wrote
he used to write his rhymes
and then i remember
there he said the last time he wrote his
rhymes he wrote his rhymes
because he was like i'll never write
again he goes that from there on out
i'ma just go in and do it and it's not
necessarily freestyling psyche as much
as i get yeah it's a form of freestyling
but it's already like they like they
just i think they're just going off
field and they have it in them and they
know what
to do and that's like a
a muscle like when you have a strength
of that muscle you're gonna kill it
you're gonna kill it
and
and um uh first of all
most people don't think i listen to hip
hop
i don't know why
what gives them that vibe
well i don't snoop up there but aside
from you got kendrick kendrick
i got too short ice cube
oh yeah
who else i got
listen not everybody can make
chappelle's wall okay not everybody can
make it okay certain people made it no i
do i do love uh
hip-hop and i love the world of hip-hop
i mean my earliest memories are is west
coast hip-hop
oh i've been revisiting uh
ice cubes uh second album death
certificate i don't know if you've taken
the time to
check that out
man
he was on a different [ __ ]
that [ __ ] have you seen straight
out of compton yeah dude
you seen the movie yeah
i don't know i don't know how many white
people seem straight out of content
no um
but so
that uh
that dis the nwa disc no vaseline it's
on that record
and it's a [ __ ]
poppin
poppin album it came i think he wanted
someone to say it came out 92 i want to
say it came out around the time he did
boys in the hood or whatever which was
obviously a classic but like if you
listen to that album it's one of those
albums from start to finish that just
[ __ ] boom boom boom boom bangers
bangers bangers
but my favorite track off there is this
one called my summer vacation kills it
and it's insane he he has this uh
i don't even know why
what's the damn line [ __ ] it [ __ ]
will you pull up the lyrics
this is gonna bug me
oh getting [ __ ] and they can't stand
the 1991 tony montana i don't know what
that means but it's dope
you know
i've never seen a black tony montana
have you
shut up meatballing and ask you
what does it say let me see
yeah
i don't know why that line maybe it's
just because of his delivery
that's the thing about hip-hop it's all
the [ __ ] delivery
but no yeah i
i've been revisiting that album
i've been
revisiting
michael jackson's stuff
uh
the thriller album
another one that's just
start to finish
bangers
have you listened to that one
come on casey lately
what
is it weird is it what oh are you
judging me for taking a no no no
it's just for jumping in a time machine
it's not in my freaking rolodex right
now
really
man you need to revisit them listen okay
if you want listen in the comments
i want people to revisit the ice cube
album
uh death certificate and tell me what
you think about it
and
and if it's your first time i want
everyone's authentic
reaction to that damn album because
you're gonna love every moment of it and
i want you to revisit thriller since no
one else in this room is doing that
i can't believe you guys how dare you
both i can't believe you didn't go to
the aquarium yeah
we're even
all right that's fair
all right that's fair i'll give you guys
that
i'll give you guys that dude uh
i watched so many live concerts there's
this one michael
uh michael jackson live
concert
i want to say he's in bucharest
how do you say it
bucharest bucharest i'm guessing i don't
know is that how you say that
yeah so funny thing about this concert
right
fast forward a little bit
no no go
go
um no
[Music]
no go back go back it's like the start
of the concert
yeah go back go back go back
okay
so
this concert specifically
so
there's this
this is how badass michael jackson is
you ready
he would do this thing where he pop out
from under the stage right
it was like the the the stage would like
throw him up and it like he like jump in
the air right and kind of hit like a
okay you see that
now he just stands there
holds it holds it the crowd going crazy
right going [ __ ] bonkers
wild thing about this
okay he stands there for like i don't
know [ __ ] two minutes or something
just looking that way you almost think
he's not real you almost think it's like
a [ __ ] robot that just came out and
is acting like michael jackson or
something like that
and then
he turns his head
to the other way
and then the crowd goes even crazier
what
think about that kind of power
or not power is just much crowd control
or whatever i don't know what i don't
know i don't know what you would call
that
what would you call that
i don't know man
exactly it's that x factor x factor i
don't know what it is
but that's like one of the dopest
[ __ ] moments what if he came out did
the jump thing looked over here for a
while looked over here for a while and i
was like thank you good night
and and you know what people would be
excited that they saw that
because that's that's how he was
we don't have i mean
listen i know people get excited for
kanye but i don't know if anyone's
gotten that level of excitement for
connie and i know i've compared kanye to
michael jackson and [ __ ] like that but i
mean this is this is different look at
him hold it he's still holding it he's
still holding it he has not given up
he has not given up
come on michael turn the head watch when
he turns his head
michael stop playing
am i going to say you is it really you
michael
they're passing out they're freaking out
they are passing out
the slow shades around the slow shade
removal
all of the above that's what i love
about his performances
because everything he did in his
performances were super calculated and
then he just starts spinning silly yeah
spinning silly
doing the damn thing look at it oh
bro
come on
come on
that no one comes out crazy outfits
anymore everyone comes out in regular
[ __ ] now i'm pretty sure everybody comes
down crazy who comes out of a crazy
outfit like that everybody name a
normally dressed musician that's like
half their thing is dressing all silly
really yeah no one comes out like that i
mean she's not wearing a
but is bts coming out like that
probably i doubt it they got regular
clothes i mean he has like a gold g
string outside justin justin bieber
justin bieber he'll wear a long t-shirt
and jeans all right yeah you're right
who else
he comes out with a pink suit
you tripping
does he even do live concerts does he
have a tour
think about it i've never heard
of a little nos x
look at how skinny his legs are i know
bro he bro michael been the same size
since he was a [ __ ] kid how do you
stay that size you don't eat what did
michael eat lettuce probably ate lettuce
or lettuce a couple of beans maybe like
four beans
is what he ate
get some fiber in them
i don't know what did michael jackson
what does it say
the veg oh the vegetarian the healthy
side today you call them beans
michael jackson's meals consisted of
green greens and beans
who am i
who am i damn he is i and i am him slim
with the tilted brim what's my
[ __ ] name
he he ate green yeah greens and beans he
liked vegetarian lasagna steamed
broccoli fresh fruits and tofu with
chili sauce
he was also a lover of soy products and
organic food the indian connection he's
sometimes like to treat himself to
indian food too
come on
what other podcast is covering michael
jackson who's who yeah who's talking
about it who's talking about it i'll
wait who else
who else is talking about michael
jackson's vegetarian diet hey shout out
to that diet though that's probably what
yeah that's why he stayed that way
what
shout out to that guy i mean
i mean hey that's what dude that made
him dance
that made him dance good
you know
listen i make my i listen i love michael
jackson i make fun of him in my act
not so much fun of him i just made fun
of both of us together you know
because we both had abusive dads
[Laughter]
shout out to abusive shout out to
abusive dads for making stars
i mean just what do you
what do you
i don't know i don't know what you make
of that but chase shout out to it you
know common denominator common there's a
common nominator michael
shout out to michael jackson
but man i you know one day i hope i
could do that with my stand up
will i just walk on stage stay stand
there
and then [ __ ] turn my head two
minutes later
i wonder how the crowd will react to
that i do have uh
dope stage presence man like when i saw
you when we were in dallas uh you do
kind of come out slow
but like just
doing like faces and like look arounds
like you're getting laughs yeah yeah
you're saying a word right out of the
gate
you know what's so funny is is a lot of
people do say that about me they're like
they're like you could look at you could
look a certain way and it's a punch line
yeah i go am i ugly or something
[ __ ] no that's just being funny
i mean you call me ugly that's probably
why you're like uh you know noticing
that and michael jackson coming out not
you know not doing something is
something in that moment yeah that's
true you know what
wow
i wonder if that's where i get it from
i mean i think that's at least why
you're able to recognize it like yeah
i guess yo yeah you're right i do kind
of look for those subtle moments and
[ __ ] like that
that's just fire
well do you know what it was it's um
because before before i started stand up
and before i even understood like
what stand-up was like because
i liked stand-up
but i didn't think anybody could do it i
thought it was just for people who were
actors because
i knew eddie eddie murphy first as an
actor for like the movies like trading
places and all that stuff
i didn't know him as stand-up because
obviously that was performed by time
so
when i you know found out he was a
stand-up as well and i would watch his
stuff i i thought it was like the
coolest [ __ ] and obviously like
you know he was able to translate
how well he was in movies and
to the stage and vice versa so like
the one thing i noticed about him he
makes a lot of faces he makes a lot of
looks that um
that just like hit big
in a dope way and so maybe i think i
probably got that from him
and also cheerleading
hey we're rooting back to hardcore
cheerleader here
hardcore cheerleader dog lacey
yeah
i think that's what they call me
make it on the necklace or something for
me already
you know give me a [ __ ] necklaces
cheerleader dog lacey but you mean in
terms of cheerleading just like stage
presence yeah because you kind of have
to
because obviously you're not talking
you're just well i mean when you shout
you know where the letters and [ __ ] but
they're saying performance wise yeah
performance-wise when you're doing a
routine in cheerleading you have to like
sell the routine you can't just have a
stone brick face
out there like that one kid in this
season of cheer they were like is
tumbling sick but his face is dog [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i think i know
which kid they were they were talking
about i actually went and visited my old
uh school
oh yeah i think i told you guys that
last year yeah i met that kid
yeah sick tumblr sick huh
he ain't no chappelle lacy
you didn't have it like that
sorry
you're talking about you're talking
about cheer dog lacy doing like
are you talking about cheer dog lacy
sorry yeah you're right
dude he was doing sick stuff though he
was doing like 900s like laid out you
were doing that too that's my bad you
talking about cheer dog lacey i didn't
realize so i was talking to you you
didn't realize who you were talking to
that's my fault watch i hate pulling
this video up but type in chapelle lacy
cheerleading those pelec skills video
skills
video right there
i hate that it has so many views no no
no starting from the top look at it
starting from the top man let me get you
started from the top man
you know let me show you let me show you
a little something about cheer dog lacy
and this was just me messing around i
just
was warming up you know
you didn't know that about me no i did
but i thought this kid was doing like
maybe it was just because it was the
show and they were like hyping them up
what was that so that was like a that
was exactly that's called a one a double
720 yeah it's called a one a double and
that's called a front through the devil
listen i'll battle any kid in the
cheerleading world now
that is sick
i didn't have to run to do that i just
hopped in the air and was like let me
put all that out there
well yeah that was back in the day that
was back when i was like [ __ ] 190
gosh to have 190 again
go on the michael jackson
bean diet
bruh if i go on that michael jackson
bean diet i'm moonwalking [ __ ] it [ __ ]
[ __ ] a back tuck i'm trying to moonwalk
that's what i'm trying to do [ __ ] he
said dude yeah
shout out to that diet you tripping
casey what are you talking about
you trimming dog
god shout out to my homegirl brooke
you didn't know that's
yeah so no that kid actually
when i was cheering
yes he probably would have been
uh better than me but but it's like
evolved so much cheerleading that like
it just
yeah he would he would kick my ass
you know but but the thing the thing
about me i was able to do both so like i
could like
you know
usually people do one on the other
like either just a tumbler
or are you stunned or also a stumbler
right yes i watched the show damn you
really did watch that show
as he leans back
shout out to that show shout out to that
show yeah so that's where i cheered the
tvcc that's where i cheered man
i and i did damn good out there man
so you better stop playing with me
i'm a real one you're right
that's the only thing i really like brag
about is how good i was at cheerleading
it's fair because who else is gonna brag
about it
who who brags about how good they were
in cheerleading besides the badass
cheerleader
i'm your hucklebeer
the western cheerleader anyways
i'm gonna do my own playlist because i
don't i don't care about any of y'all
[Laughter]
hey people have really been enjoying
these playlists yeah people mention it a
lot you know what else has been really
cool too
is um and thank you guys for this when
i'm on the road
there are people that come up to me and
talk about how much they
uh love listening to chappelle's world
so it means a lot and i love doing this
podcast and you know and i feel like
it's growing and growing and i'm having
fun doing these solo episodes as well
and um
you know we'll try to get some uh
dope guests as well i think we got
you know
we got stevie wonder coming on soon
he said something remember he met yeah
he messaged about yeah i'm pretty sure
yeah stevie wonder was like oh dude i
would i would love why why wouldn't i
come on your show uh big oasis fan big
big oasis fan so he was like dude we
could talk oasis all day you know i was
like shout out to stevie wonder uh
freaking robert plant from led zeppelin
said he would come on in a heartbeat he
said yes i would love to come on your
show
that was my best british accent
it wasn't bad it wasn't
no
anyways man let me do this [ __ ] play
so
playlist we'll start off okay
are there any bands from springfield
missouri
[Music]
that we can put on here
we can throw in the playlist
are any of these uh
john duckworth
speedy west
not speedy west the speedy west i think
he actually
dm'd us he wants to come on the show too
speedy west is going to come on the show
there you here ladies and gentlemen
speedy west
is coming on the show
well all right i'm trying to do my uh
springfield missouri justice but guess i
couldn't with the playlist all right so
i'll just make them all
let's do we'll start off with we're
talking about jay-z let's do jay-z
encore i say encore because
kanye did that beat
right
and when they were making it
i think he talked about the part whether
whether they chant ho
hover
dude
when you see him do that live in that
dock
you get chills kanye gives you chills
not with what he's doing now
[Laughter]
not with the what you see in the media
maybe it gives you a different kind of
chills like ooh that's [ __ ] weird
the chills i'm talking about when it
comes
to his creative process
so jay-z encore
um we can do
oh we'll do
uh
my summer vacation
uh ice cube
we'll do that
um since i was performing on 311 day
in springfield missouri right
so we'll give 311 a shout out
um
let's go with 311.
there's so many good ones
let's go with creatures
we'll go 311 creatures
um
let's see
[Music]
oh we'll go with michael jackson
let's go would want to be starting
something
did i remember that the the
the funny thing about that song well not
funny i remember when i was living in
kentucky i was down and out
dark days for me
uh one of the many in my life
and there's an ending part i want to be
starting something before he does a mama
saying
he says it's like dope part that makes
you like believe in yourself remember i
wrote it down on a piece of paper and
kept it in my wallet
and i lost that wallet
so
shout out to that wallet shout out to
that wallet shouts out to that wallet uh
so did michael jackson want to be
starting something
um
who else
we can do
damn there's so many
michael jackson oh we can do let's do
jackson five as well let's do jackson
five
stop the love you save
stop
[Music]
and if you're interested like i know
people
um i know i watch a lot of like live
concerts
uh
if you're ever interested in which ones
are some of my favorites
i'm always down to like just you know
dm or like comment and i'll
um meatball runs the chapelle's world
page but i'll tell him or whatever and
you can watch those kind watch those
concerts they're dope so the the one i
want you to watch is
the jackson the 30-year
anniversary or whatever that's a dope
performance
um
let's see jay-z encore ice cube summer
vacation 311 creatures michael jackson
one of you starting something jackson
five stop the love you save
um
[Music]
man
shoot what should we hit him with
what else did i talk about casey i
talked a lot about springfield
springfield rocks springfield rocks
i love you springfield
you know you know that reference drew
carey show yeah yeah really but they say
cleveland rocks
[Laughter]
uh
see oh yeah did i talk about this that's
it well we said kendrick all right let's
do a kendrick song
song
[ __ ] don't kill my vibe
we'll get we'll get actually we'll get a
little west coast with this let's do
nipsy hustle
let's do hustle and motivate
whoever would have thought the jackson
five would make the same playlist as
[ __ ] nifty hustle and kendrick lamar
i knew 311 would
[Laughter]
so we have libsyo so
uh
let's do
ooh we could do schoolboy q
you like schoolboy q meatball
yeah
uh we'll do collard greens
that's a good one
it's so funny because i i talk so much
[ __ ] to meatball and just yell at him
and he like people can't hear him reply
back so they probably just think he's in
the corner
so sad and upset it kind of is oh shut
up don't do that
oh the group chat's lit
meatball says every environment he works
for at thick boy studios is great but
mine
um
jay-z encore ice cube
um
let's do another jay-z
we'll do another jay-z we'll do
something about that black album
we'll do exchange clothes
here they go
what's that song actually called
hold on
it's with him and pharrell
you looking at me crazy because i like
to look this way on my phone
mm-hmm
oh it's called change clothes
i should have [ __ ] known that
can i throw in drake is drake allowed on
a playlist
chapelle's world man oh no
drake
with drake's song what i [ __ ]
he's got so many
you uh all right i'll do this drake song
i'll do the song over
i remember when i first started stand up
okay
i was like
you know i was on this weird like
you know i'm a stand-up comedian i'm
gonna be a star
type [ __ ] guy i could never picture
you with that energy but oh my god it
was like it was so stupid and i remember
so when around the time i had started
stand up
was when drake like came out and he was
like rising
right he had that like mix tape that has
uh forever on it
so like he was having this buzz right
and i thought i would have that buzz as
a stand-up community
got a dream big dream big there get up
and i was dude i thought i was so
[ __ ] cool
and i remember i'd make these make these
like i would burn these cds because you
can still burn cds and make these
[ __ ] and i put all these drinks songs
on it they're all like motivational and
have me going and i was like yeah man
i'll be a star like you know i thought i
was going to have the buzz
that drake i really over hyped myself
and then the fourth show i ever did i
got booed and cussed that
and then i was like oh i'm not drake
right back to her right right back to
[ __ ] square
one but anyways the over was like yeah
man i could see myself now being in the
theater performing i'll walk out to
drake over
and you were like i could see myself
performing in springfield yeah sitting
on a bear let's go back to that bear
picture actually casey is obsessed with
this
look hey you see what's in my hand
latte baby that is a ice mocha
i don't know why i put it in a warm cup
but it has that is a iced mocha
in that cup
damn good ice smoker too
anyways how many how many was on that
list
that's tim all right we'll do that we'll
close it off with drake over because
that [ __ ] slaps and when you listen to
and people that are gonna bump this
playlist when you listen over
just think of yourself as this
big [ __ ] in your universe
anyways thank you guys for tuning in
means a lot uh thank you for really
enjoying yeah because the last solo
episode got a great response as well
uh [ __ ] [ __ ] we're just gonna keep
punching these [ __ ] out why not
you know uh and then when stevie wonder
comes on that'll be you know
the first one back so i got some dates
coming up um
listen if you guys can show up like
springfield
you know i'm
i don't know i might talk about your
city on this show
i don't know but you gotta you gotta you
gotta i don't know if you can outdo
springfield but let's give it a shot so
april 8th and april 9th i'll be in salt
lake city utah i know you guys get
pretty hyped over there but um you know
let's see how hard you can go and then
san diego may 6th to may 7th at a new
comedy club called mic drop comedy club
uh
and yeah in san diego that's may 6th and
7th tickets are up right now and then
may 12th uh i'll be doing a one-nighter
in my hometown uh phoenix arizona it's
stand-up live just one night only uh i'm
bringing joel uh joel used to be the
drummer part of kill tony crew uh does
all the roast battles and stuff like
that so he'll be featuring for me it'll
be a great time and uh those are the
dates i have coming up so far i i think
i have rhode island in june uh haven't
added those dates yet those will be
added soon but uh all tickets and all
touring information at chapelleac.com
uh thank you thank you for watching
continue to like subscribe leave dope
comments uh also uh one thing if if you
have like an artist that you want me to
check out because a lot of people do
send me these recommendations um throw
them in the comments you know uh i'll
check them out or meatball we'll check
them out and then i'll listen to them
and give a genuine uh review of what i
think of the artist also we got a lot of
good uh band name suggestions in the
comments last episode so keep those
coming oh yeah keep them rolling
boom
you